you know it's so unnatural to talk to
you while looking at the camera oh yeah
how do you tubers just do this for so
long you know well you just look at you
but you know it's okay I don't you got
stairs you just carry it out high reject
nation I'm Greg Alba we're gonna watch
the day from our friends at screen
junkies the honest trailer is for all
right I don't know when I'm supposed to
have my match or damn Merle for the
championship belts I'm coming for you
Dan I'm gonna find out which lines you
wrote here I'm gonna just criticize
writing such a fan of Dan I'm a fan of
the man who was dead really am watch
them all the time some excited for it
any hope before we hop into this I
wanted to say thank you everyone who has
joined us on her patron page Joe had a
great successful year in 2018 grew quite
a lot over there we do weekly Q&A Stevie
Show reaction watch along for many a
shows that includes attack on Titan Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood my hero
academia Riverdale Gotham and
supernatural and this guy also does
music video coverage so go check out our
patreon page yeah we post plenty over
there exclusive goodies
that's a hop add into this yah
from the studio that model let's play
with their toys to see on screen - they
did sick as long as you're the kind of
person who says there's need extreme 90s
era of leather jackets an attitude no
just of the most with a roller and in
bra as he plays the investigative
reporter like a crackhead squirrel
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a quiet place audiences everywhere
- no animal we've been advised overhead
does Eddie get to crap out the stolen
favorite parts that got cut out of
Charmin action let's stop enjoying it
while they bore you to death with
science talk you need nuanced depth Ruby
did research
the web is the not-so-secret visible
call to drag a man who wants to destroy
humanity in order to save it it
we brought the planet to imprint of
extinction of last year by this film's
villain infinity Wars reason thick
troponin each other like a visualizer
with T changed into a comic book fill
that is involved by 20 other episodes
like the MCU before the greatest
protections of the DC Universe man
because sometimes it's fun to watch it
movie that's just a movie it's so well
probably the kick-started entire
cinematic universe Oh
[Music]
hell yeah knock knock with the devil in
um Matt was an epic darkness trailer
wasn't epic on his trailer reminded me
of some things that had kind of blocked
out of my mind for all that fun five
minutes long you're like in December
their shows are a little bit shorter
yeah maybe
no elf one was like a minute can you
really nitpick about does someone need a
hug so they were talking about how Tom
Hardy like they were making fun of all
the noises he makes like it's this
weather they covered his mouth you know
that joke and I was watching an
interview and I think it might have been
with Danielle Radford from screen
junkies news where she was interviewing
Tom Hardy and she brought that up and he
didn't seem like he had some prepared
joke answer it really seemed like it was
the first time this was ever addressed
to him like the way he was responding to
it was like do i I guess I do play a lot
of characters whose faces are covered no
but yeah something never actually hit
his consciousness about it and it's
funny too because I saw a different
interview where he said that part of his
inspiration for Eddie Brock's that he
didn't tell the producers about was he
was basing a lot of it on Woody Allen oh
really yeah
like the mannerisms and the kind of
neuroses of Woody Allen and stuff like
that trying to channel ya which when you
watch this in like a weird little medley
of just awkward moments kind of comes
through yeah that's true
but looking back on the movie I can
actually see that that's true that's a
good point which is like I always find
it hilarious and these kinds of contexts
really Wow Woody Allen is just not who I
would have thought of for a venom movie
inspiration you know even behind the
scenes but I work for that uncomfortable
awkward humor yeah that actually does
fit yeah really well cuz that is what
Woody Allen excels in they didn't like
mirror him no it wasn't like Will
Ferrell in that one movie where he
played Woody Allen oh god I was like on
Melinda Melinda it was like the drama
and the comedy version yeah was that I
love that they brought that point though
about the villain trope about villain
wanting to destroy human it's like we
had this era where is like cliche
mustache furling villain and then we had
this weird thing where it was villain
wanted to be caught yeah and then we
were in sky beam territory I beam and
now we have self yes I want to help the
world by sea destroy because that makes
you go as a viewer I get where he's
coming from Mohammed was even Aquaman
sort of had that a little bit with arm
kind of what he's like look at what the
surface people do to our waters and
stuff you know like it was environmental
issues and how we're destroying the
planet how humanity's doing it so they
need to be wiped and cleanse it's like a
cleansing yeah there's a matter as a
virus yeah it's kind of an annoying
trope but it's a it's a thing we always
go into this thing with villains where
we always see this like repeat patterns
of what we always borrow from movies of
what but it is kind of an annoying trope
so much of our cinematic landscape right
now or what accounts for so much of that
is world domination plots and all that
big blockbuster movies and so like it
highlights this idea that it's kind of
tricky to make them all not resemble
each other in some way shape or form
especially when they get made so quickly
now yeah and there's such a wide variety
and you know that these people are
talking behind the scenes and stuff as
these movies are in production and so
and then if someone's just good old pure
evil it's like a
yes you can't win I wonder what we're
going to migrate to next is the new
villain trope you know like the new
domination scheme I kind of feel like
the next trope is something along the
lines of a kill monger and Black Manta
okay
I'll be black know of people who are
wronged and you get why they feel
wronged that's a good call you know like
kill monger was totally wrong so that's
what you understand him black mana was a
dick upfront with this whole backstory I
want in case you haven't seen it yeah
but there's a moment but those are like
yeah yeah I think that's gonna be the
next wave of things is to make a villain
effective and to sympathize for him yeah
but all this talk about villainies why
you're listening to this part of us
talking about an honest trailer this is
the true villainy is the love story bit
to do you know and in China they there's
a real posters l AO a marketed because
it's a box office like I heard it killed
a giant yeah and what they did was they
marketed as if this like joke of venom
is a love story between him and Eddie
Brock or I ship venom and Eddie hardcore
100% either venom and Eddie Brock is the
love story or it's a love story of you
know Michelle Williams and all
that'sthat's the be love stories to be
like is helping himself because we are
vet fair fair enough and even the
Michelle Williams love story she has
venom in her at one point so really it's
all the same it's all the same I'm
surprised I didn't talk about the thing
that a lot of people complain about
which is the turn of venom of what he's
like a mud platica loser like that thing
that everyone seems to really get mad
about which I thought was charming and
funny I did too and maybe that maybe
that's why is is like it is just one of
those things that's kind of weird but
also adorable about yeah movie and it is
something interesting that shines out
amid some of the film's more rough Ellen
gee or is she venom hot idea I mean
she's like totally skinned conforming
yeah curvy it's a little weird with her
head action but you know if you just had
Michelle in his head it would just look
like she had a latex costume yeah if she
just had better teeth as she yeah
be pretty attracts conflicted and I'm
sure there are some people out there who
think that it's super hot I would have
loved that scene if he like pulled in
sheep and was like come here and then
morph satyrs like what the [ __ ] oh oh
do it I thought you were just venom form
I would yeah you've been inside of me
there are no secrets no no secrets
anyway guys thanks honest trailer screen
junkies crew for putting this bad boy
together what a way to kick off your new
year by hitting the trending page it
were like top 5 trending on YouTube with
this one you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and hey check us out on patreon yo
we got a lot of goodies